right or left most Americans love
teachers we honor you and every citizen
called to the noble vocation of teaching
but often the agreement stops there and
the biggest dispute today has to do with
funding teachers the teachers salaries
are a local issue it's an issue that
crosses state lines and these teachers
say their complaints go beyond a
personal paycheck materials in the
classroom that are outdated we have mice
and cockroaches since 1969 the PDK poll
has surveyed the public's attitude
towards public education the poll always
asked respondents about the biggest
problem facing the local public school
since 2002 the most common answer has
been funding 22 percent cited it as the
biggest issue in 2017 outranking
standards lack of good teachers violence
and drugs Secretary of Education Betsy
DeVos advocates for more school choice
and at times less federal funding some
say you can see the outcome of that type
of agenda in Arizona Arizona has made
those cuts and the result is that
students don't have what they need to
learn teachers can't afford to work
without also having a second job others
say US schools can and should be better
but the solution is more than just
funding we ought to be paying teachers
more but that ought to be part of a
bargain where we're paying teachers more
and making sure we're retooling what
teachers and schools do so that they're
equipped to get our kids where they need
to go the strike in Arizona could end
this week if the governor's proposed
budget deal passes the proposed deal
would increase Arizona teachers pay by
10% next year and restore a three
hundred seventy million dollar funding
cut over the next of five years